[Music]
in this morning Saturday session a rare
look inside a record label that's
changing the way music is recorded and
released Third Man Records is the
brainchild of Jack White of the White
Stripes founded in 2001 Jack and his
team have built a unique music Empire
we'll have a performance from their
newest artist Lily May in a moment but
first we took a tour when Third Man
Records opened its new vinyl pressing
plant in Detroit in February it was a
landmark in the unexpected Renaissance
of vinyl records the eight German maid
machines are the first new presses to be
built in about 35 years
all new presses new boilers new
hydraulics new piping everything is
brand new what made you want to take
that leap an incredible sense of not
knowing when to stop musician Jack White
who was born in the Motor City has
Detroit sized dreams for his record
label one day I want this place to be
like what I had heard about Henry Ford
wanted for a Ford Motor Company which
was you pouring raw materials on this
side and out the other side of the
factory pop out cars you want the whole
line and we're closed now the only thing
we're not doing is plating and making
the sleeves
white who made his name as frontman for
the White Stripes launched third man to
re-release the group's records on vinyl
it was a passion project my company has
always done well we've always profited
which I always thought it would always
be a loss yeah and you weren't figuring
you're gonna make any money on them no
no
vinyl records he set up a warehouse in
Nashville in 2009 and recruited old
friend Ben Swank to run it was there a
plan in the beginning for third man
record you know honestly the most
contentious thing between my wife at
that time was you don't even have a
business plan what are you doing out
front of the warehouse they opened a
small record shop it became so popular
it quickly grew into a kind of candy
land for music junkies and third man
began to expand its roster of artists
adding country legend Wanda Jackson
recording Loretta Lynn and new singer
Margo price the eclectic catalog also
includes spoken word recordings like
auctioneer jerry king so if you drop the
needle here it's a cattle auction but if
you drop it here it's a tobacco auction
now 133 now pile but it 133 bye buddy
133 grams so why do you do because it's
it should exist at third man packaging
design is as important as the music
itself this is a limited edition
soundtrack to the great gatsby so these
are actually playable platinum coated
records oh these are wood sleeves yeah
they're wooden sleeves and then we we
riveted them ourselves
it's not just what's on the vinyl but
what's in it we pressed flower petals
into the record you plus flap now yeah a
recording of the late astronomer Carl
Sagan has a special look we did it on
this glow-in-the-dark we call it cosmic
slop vinyl some things that were
gimmicky some things that were beautiful
anything to capture attention of people
to bring back to the physical product
and get away from invisible music and
disposable music white who started his
career as a furniture upholsterer has
lavished the same attention to detail
on third man's Nashville headquarters
over an archway an upside-down turntable
is carved into the wood I care more
about how to design this room and I do a
lot how many of those records are going
to sell music feels like a
three-dimensional thing for you in the
sense that the artwork and everything
else around it you know I sort of lay in
bed thinking a lot of it is a waste of
my time because I don't know how much of
it really connects and follows through
and especially in the day and age that I
was dropped on planet Earth to work in
the day and age where people music is
the last thing on their mind after their
cellphone Netflix
Internet where I used to think when when
music was really number-one on people's
list I used to feel sorry for poets and
sculptors you know now I feel sorry for
ourselves because of what we're
competing against and so are when we see
teenager come in and buy a record that
just lights us all up this year vinyl is
expected to become a billion-dollar
industry third man now releases about a
record a week some captured from live
performances in the Blue Room at the
back of the headquarters where they can
record directly onto acetate
use to create the vinyl master we think
we're the only live venue in the world
where you can do this
this recording was of third man's latest
artist Lillie Mae a 25 year old fiddling
phenom Lillie Mae Rishi started
performing in the family band when she
was just three some musics literally in
your blood I think it is I think it is
at seven her older sister told her to
pick up the fiddle and obviously you
liked the fiddle I hated it
you did hear it really I hated it
but she came around and caught the ear
of white who recruited her for his
backing band she is you know sort of
that Michael Jackson of the Jackson five
she is to me that family every one of
them is talented but she's got that
something that's extra special about her
[Music]
white produced Lillie Mae's debut record
what's it like to see that album right
it was pretty wild I got to see it last
week I got to see a copy of it I was
like it was just crazy